[Music]
one thing that no one has on the street
is recycling which is really really sad
as 2016 and living downtown Los Angeles
and there's no method of recycling what
what did you find
this is a camera mounted light and
there's something in there yeah these
are brand new from a pitcher and someone
threw that away yeah these are brand-new
brand-new yeah the guys at aperture have
been super cool and sending us a bunch
of stuff and then all of a sudden I
found two aperture lights that were
accidentally tossed who put them in here
we don't know this is the Connery did I
fail the delegate or did the person who
did that fail to listen to my
instructions this is not your fault
common sense dictates that if you're
gonna throw a cardboard box away you
look to make sure that there's nothing
else in it before you pitch it oh did
you throw this box away with two videos
so far on trying to make a VR backpack
first attempt unsuccessful we didn't
have enough power for the laptop second
attempt goes with this gigabyte laptop
the ORU's the laptop ran games just fine
and plugged in oh and unplugged the
laptop battery it actually still ran the
games but only ran them for about 15
minutes the solution is to make the
laptop think it's plugged in by plugging
it into a much more powerful battery
Horus x7 made by gigabyte and this
laptop has a desktop 980 GPU in it VR
games are so demanding it's to 1900 by
1,200 screens earning at 90 frames per
second we need to make it mobile Spencer
and I came up with a plan
these are 1600 milliamp hour lipo
batteries and this battery would power
this laptop for over an hour
however this battery runs at twenty two
point two volts and this laptop requires
19 volts we devised a little solution
right here is a voltage step-down clock
we're going to feed the battery into
this puck step down the voltage and then
run that into the laptop hopefully all
that combined will have a nice easy to
use the our rig no wires swing your arms
while they fight all those demons with
your giant swords and not
into your wire ever again and that is
the ultimate gaming experience you guys
wanna hear a story
here's fun little story for you guys
happened this morning still asleep wrote
oh my cat starts bouncing next to the
mic back back it's kind of annoying
I'm still trying to sleep but like
whatever and she she likes to chew stuff
she actually chewed a hole in the sheet
my calm man wrote is just playing play
the thorn part of the sheet again
whatever was getting on her ha ha funny
kitty she keeps doing that am i I wrote
oh you gotta stop it's really annoying
ham you just like your paws right next
to the whole time let's it up can i push
her away and as I do so a cockroach
dissipate comes running out of the
sheets right next to me once you get is
I think she caught it somewhere else in
the place carry it up up onto the bed
play with it with me so the whole time
she was like giving my side Weezer's a
cockroach cuddled up to me as spooning
me while I was sleeping
cockroach scurried along the bed I went
oh [ __ ] grab my blankets and covered it
up and then I didn't deal with killing
it somehow yeah good times right now I'm
trying to put the wires in to the input
side which is coming from our battery
into this little adapter it does it's
converting to go to a lower voltage
that's the main purpose of this thing
killing me smalls killing me what's
killing you
smalls oh yeah hate that guy that's our
power in now shut up at multimeter it
says twenty four point two is when our
masters let's go and see what our cell
states are on this
24.4 cool I'm not too happy with this do
we have any electrical tape oh you guys
are covered okay got again got our out
now time to go into the laptop I guess
checking our output 2.6 so that's good
we're getting a proper proper image out
all right this is a big moment of truth
right here if the charging icon shows up
on the laptop you know it's working
alright here we go hope we don't explode
okay we're drying point one eight amps
hey this is plugged in we tricked it
aren't you excited Spencer I'm very cool
I work yeah we're getting a pretty
consistent poll right now yeah that's
that's not good
no that's a hot cable for sure yeah it
basically what that means is we're
drawing too much through the cable like
the cables not ready
I brought the laptop over here I have my
little live station set up the laptop is
not plugged into the wall Spencer is
going to bring the battery over we're
going to plug it in we're gonna see just
how hot things get literally actually
because the cable running from the
battery to the laptop is from getting
too hot
I'm a rolling VR but everyone get some
more heat off of this now that some
actual amperage is being pulled through
it but I think you'll give power up a
game I guess all right here I'm watching
swordmaster vo7 weirds going on and
getting some abnormalities it's not
pulling the amperage needs to yep frame
it's checked for mode it got smooth and
then it dropped down again see it smooth
it's smooth it's great it's great it's
all working but it's all working now
what happened it's running fantastically
well now it's not it's like it's
flipping back and forth between battery
and wall outlet okay that's
corresponding to I'm seeing over here
for
well I think we need a thicker wire this
adapter is getting really hot how hot
119 now and the cable 105 it's holding
strong at a low framerate like it's not
actually crashing it gives me the
impression it's sucking power but not
sucking enough power from the readings
I'm getting from this thing for not
getting what we should feel like it's
just a matter of wires now we gotta get
the right wires we got a big [ __ ]
hey what's up Sam and Nico second-unit
surprise bet and there were people on
today's video that are commenting like
all the Titan X is better aren't the
Tesla's of the Quadros it's like they're
more powerful they are not better
there's a difference
better is power per dollar the 1080 is a
very powerful card at a decent price a
Titan X is a more powerful card at a
much more expensive price if you break
it down to like kodokor per dollar it's
much more expensive for the tight next
and so therefore we're able to get more
1080s for the same price the tekneqs is
twice as expensive as the 1080 but it's
not twice as powerful
so by pure logic it's not a better card
having just a crap ton of co2 cores will
make my rendering faster that's pretty
much all I care about then we get in
comments like this like I mean it's not
like the Titan X exists or anything or
Tesla's or quadros then another guys
like had no clue about the technology
that they use to make a living it's
hilarious to watch they've baited me
they baited me I have to respond now